[Musique]
sophie petro n'en est de nouveau au mali
cette travailleuse humanitaire
franco-suisse de 76 ans avait passé
quatre ans détenu par des djihadistes
qui est un peu le sentiment qu'elle se
fout de nous elle a finalement été
libéré rapport le contre la libération
de 200 jihadistes elle fait désormais
l'objet d'un avis de recherche de la
gendarmerie malienne qui demande à
toutes les unités de la localiser de
l'appréhender pour sa propre sécurité
l'effort qui a été consenti pour la
libérer une première fois ne pourra pas
être le même et ça c'est assez clair
nous avons des soldats qui ont été tués
dans le cadre d'opérations pour aller
secourir des otages qui avaient été
faits prisonniers dans des pays
étrangers
il faut avoir donc du respect aussi pour
nos soldats pendant combien de temps
encore on va être les cocus de même
petrona la france bien sûr avec toi qui
vas aller perdre la vie pour cette
bouffonne non mais enfin qui va les
perdre la vie pour cette bouffonne
depuis 9h20 de ce matin les femmes
travaillent gratuitement selon eurostat
l'écart de rémunération entre les femmes
et les hommes est en moyenne de 16 5% en
2021 mohamed beau gars à qui a reçu le
prix goncourt c'est le benjamin du carré
final il a 31 ans eric adams devient le
deuxième mère afro américains de la
ville de new york avec 70 % des
suffrages il a remporté haut la main la
ville de huit millions et demi
d'habitants son ouvrage est absolument
sublime il s'appelle la plus secrète
histoire des hommes je sois le premier
africain subsaharien par exemple a
remporté le prix goncourt peut paraître
oui exceptionnel mais l'idéal serait
précisément que ça ne le soit plus ces
visuels publiées sur les réseaux sociaux
montrent des femmes aux visages moitié
découvert moitié revêtue d'un voile
islamique avec ce slogan en anglais la
beauté est dans la diversité comme la
liberté et dans le hidjab cette vidéo
prône le voile comme élément identitaire
et évidemment c'est contraire donc de
fait la france a fait valoir et bien sa
désapprobation et sa condamnation vive
doudou le retrait les contribuable
français paie une campagne de
communication orchestrée
on le voit en sous main par des
islamistes des associations qui sont des
faux nez antiracistes qui sont en fait
les associations proches des frères
musulmans créée spécifiquement pour
faire du lobbying auprès des instances
européennes en laissant croire que le
voile islamiste est une illustration de
la liberté les institutions européennes
présentent un acte de soumission comme
un acte de liberté il faut que la france
pensait d'eux je propose qu elle ne
participe plus à son fonctionnement
qu'elle arrête son financement suspect
financement la france millions d'euros
tous les 18 joueurs n'allaient devant le
monument et bien il ya un type qui s'est
mis à cracher sur ces gens là moi je
n'accepte pas voilà ce qui me distingue
houle une distinction je vais le
surnommer le maréchal zemmour parce
qu'il défend le maréchal pétain voilà ça
lui fera du bien le destin que je crains
pour la fin de libres c'est-à-dire une
arrivée le liban exactement une arrivée
massive de populations musulmanes qui
déséquilibre la démographie alors que le
pays était majoritairement chrétien avec
un pays désormais en banqueroute se
nourrir est devenu au liban un combat de
tous les jours dans cette épicerie deux
fois moins de clients deux fois moins de
denrées également parce que les prix de
ventes s'envolent et aujourd'hui la
misère c'est exactement ce qui nous
attend si nous n'arrêtons pas le grand
remplacement ce fromage là on le vendait
l'équivalent de 3 euros maintenant pour
un libanais il vaut l'équivalent de 18
euros
la même les packs d'eau ont vu leur prix
multipliés par six
[Applaudissements]
les sens un prêt qui a été multiplié par
8 ces derniers mois on a fait les
calculs ça représente 8 euros le litre